Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
authored by of
in the fifth chapter the chapter of
the chapter of vigilance
meaning vigilance of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala vigilance of Allah's sight
vigilance of Allah's listening vigilance
of Allah's observation
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala observes
us wherever we are and he has placed us
here in this earth in order to
manifest our true colors
inshallah after this chapter this is
the fifth chapter once we finish this
chapter which is kind of a lengthy
chapter actually so it would be
probably another week or so. We are
going to take a detour
in the same book and go to the book
of seeking knowledge in this in
because
a composition of multiple books. One of
those books is the book of knowledge.
We're going to go through that book of
knowledge inshallah with respect to the
the the virtues of knowledge. The
virtues of the people of knowledge, the
virtues of seeking knowledge, the
incredible baraka and the necessity
of seeking knowledge, some of the
etiquets of seeking knowledge, and then
we'll circle back around inshallah to
the sixth chapter.
[Silence]
Have we heard of the the book of the 40
narrations.
The 40 narrations of Noi. Everybody's
heard of this book, right? Albunawi,
the 40 Noi narrations. It's actually 42
narrations, but that book is probably
one of the most ubiquitous,
commonplace,
well-known
compilations of narrations in the
history of Islam. Everyone knows this
book. It was authored by the same author
here.
and and Noahi his writings and
his compilations and his compositions
are golden and many of them were
considered to be landmark
landmark
writings in his time even before his
death.
Now that narration that book of
narrations is usually the most
that is the beginner book of
narrations. Usually all students begin
with the 40 narrations of a noi. Right?
I began with the 40 narrations of a noi.
Our teachers began with us with the 40
narrations of a noi. when you want to
memorize hadith or you want to study
hadith that's the first book that you
begin with. Now what is the point of
these 42 narrations that
compiled? The point of that book is
that those 42 narrations
are considered to be the essence of all
of the rest of the narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. Those 42
narrations, each one of them is
considered to be a principle
of Islam
which many other rulings of Islam are
referred to. There are there are no
matters in Islam
and the study of Islam that don't that
cannot be referred back to those 40
narrations. All of the taps of the Quran
can be had through those 40
narrations. These are considered to be
theul
of Islam. the
founding pillars of Islam and
knowledge in different in different
aspects, whether it be in iman, whether
it be in etiquette, whether it be in in
halal and haram, whether it be in
law, whether it be in disputes, whatever
it is. And so he of course attempted to
compile the most critical narrations
which all other narrations are going to
be based upon in those 40 narrations. In
this chapter we have three of those 40
narrations in a row. So the narration we
just finished which was the narration of
that is one of those narrations.
The second is this narration the
narration of Muadb
and
then the narration to come will be the
narration of Ib Abbas with respect to
belief in decree. So these narrations
are critical narrations that if a person
understands these narrations properly
properly and understands the intent
behind them, a person will have
understood a great deal of knowledge. A
great deal of knowledge and wisdom. This
narration is no exception. This is one
of those 40 narrations.
It's on the authority of
why those two because those two why
those two narrators together
these two men narrate the same narration
from the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam who can tell me why
I've mentioned it before I'm not asking
you a question that I haven't already g
giving you the answer to.
Look at this. We have a historian
amongst us. Those were the two that were
sent to Yemen together.
Abu Dar and Muel were sent to Yemen by
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam in
the seventh or eighth year after Hij
some mention the ninth. Okay. And they
were sent to Yemen as judges.
and as
collectors of zak
and duat to call the people of Yemen to
Islam.
Now why is that? Well, the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam sent messengers
and he sent letters to all of the
surrounding
areas
and the people of Yemen. Some of them
had accepted Islam
and they sent for a scholar to be sent
to them to teach them Islam and to call
to Islam
and to
regulate the those who become Muslim
there and those who do not become Muslim
but to be act as judges there. And so he
sent
and he sent Abu Darbad.
And when he sent them, he gave them
pieces of advice.
pieces of advice with respect to how to
call the people to Islam,
advice with respect to how to deal with
one another while they are there, and
advice with upon which they should base
their intentions and their behavior
while they are there.
This narration is one of those pieces of
advice. The prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam sent them to represent him
and he is saying to them
this is what I want you to base your
behavior on make this your the basis of
all of your of everything you do while
you're there whether you're by yourself
or you're in public dealing with
non-Muslims or Muslims dealing with
combatants or dealing with peaceful
this is what the basis of your your
actions needs to be. And so he told them
three things.
If we were to take this narration, I I
believe that a lot of us have heard this
narration already. The narration of
annis
none of you will truly believe until he
loves for his brother what he loves for
himself.
And
[Silence]
these narrations that I'm saying. You
notice that I'm saying the beginning
part and you all are telling me the the
continuation. What does this mean? This
means that we already know these
narrations.
However, these narrations that we take
for granted,
they are lifechanging.
These narrations that I just mentioned,
those three or four narrations,
honestly, honestly, if we individually,
every one of us were to take up those
narrations sincerely and honestly
and practice them to perfection, even if
we were only to practice 20% of them,
30% of them,
the
world in which we exist, right now
would change.
What did the companions change the world
with? Was it with money? Was it with the
sword as it said? Was it with military
might? Was it with cunning? No. It was
with these pieces of narrations, these
pieces of wisdom that they took to heart
and they believed unwaveringly
and they fulfilled to their last breath
as best as they could. They took it
seriously and they were not afraid of
change. They looked at change in the
face and they embraced it. And the world
changed because of a couple hundred guys
in the middle of the desert.
How many were at the battle of Badr? 300
and some 300 and some men. The entire
world's history was altered. Not only
that, but you and I are sitting in this
masid right now. This masid exists
because of those men taking these
narrations seriously.
How could 1,500
years
really endure in this way? And there's
no,
you know, it's not Islam is
fizzling out anytime soon. And so we
know these narrations. It's just an
issue of what? Implementation.
Have we heard of the man named
A lot of people have heard this name
and he's usually known as being a person
of wisdom, right? But what a lot of
people don't know about
is he was a contemporary of Imam Melik
and he is the most advanced student of
Sophiana.
And not only that, but
he is considered to be if not more
knowledgeable and capable than Im Malik,
no less.
But the difference is is once they both
studied together, they were peers. Al
Malik
was appointed as the MUI of Medina
and im etc. And
excused himself and receded into the
corners. He didn't involve himself in
teaching. He didn't involve himself in
hadith and he spent his time in worship
and in private. He was a very private
man. But he has narrations many
narrations. And some of the students of
hadith came to
getting a narration from
is getting
a rare commodity. It is priceless,
right? And so they came to him and they
said,
"Narrate to us a narration."
What was his response?
He said you are people who are upon
misguidance. You're being swindled by a
shaitan.
We're asking you for narrations of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
You're telling us we're being swindled?
Yes. Because he's not going to narrate
to them anything that they don't already
know. They're not asking for narrations
because they need them. They're asking
for narrations for vanity.
They want to narrate from
that's all.
And so he said,
[Silence]
He said, "If every time you are given a
bite to eat, you throw it behind you and
you don't take it and swallow it and
ingest it and embody it, when are you
going to ever be satisfied?"
They don't need any new knowledge. Like
Abdah Mubarak said, who's another of the
he said,
He said we are more in need of a little
bit of of etiquette than we are of a
lot of knowledge. We are not suffering
from a lack of knowledge. As Muslim mean
in general when we say knowledge, we're
not suffering from a lack of knowledge.
We're suffering from a lack of
implementation of what we already know.
And obey Allah and Allah will teach you.
But if a person takes knowledge as a
vanity, then when will they ever be
satisfied?
Subhanahu
is
[Silence]
very